if you're if you're talking opinion
pieces I got no qualms nobody because I
do exactly that yeah I do my opinion
segments and I'll put Trump slam for
this reason because I'm quite literally
opining on my thoughts I'll be like Joe
Biden roasted for doing this thing and
I'll say this is why people are angry
because I'm doing opinion commentary
right but for our straight new stuff I'm
like
just tell us what happened first well I
don't think majority people are even
reading that like they're not clicking
through and seeing the category opinion
op-ed they're not seeing that they're
just seeing the headline so they're just
taking oh this is news and it comes from
a reputable Source or well I mean
reputable back to the context of the
McCarthy stuff Adam Schiff was was using
his position on the intelligence
committee to claim evidence existed that
was you know confidential that the
American people couldn't see yeah and
then they just had to trust him for it
yeah and he was lying so then you get
journalists who write confirmed evidence
exists Trump clue with Russia and it's
like bro some guy just said that